so
um
so uh today I'm going to present how to
apply the stochastic approximation
results to various reinforcement
learning algorithms so let's start with
uh reinforcement and I think at this
stage of this program probably I don't
need to introduce okay this is me or
actually by the way the picture in
siva's notes was me uh 12 years ago so
this is
foreign
okay so reinforced learning is used to
solve large scale sequential decision
making problems and there are there are
many successful stories I listed a few
here so probably it starts with this
Atari game where this dqn becomes
popular and then we have this famous
artifago which beats the best human
player in the world
and then we have this uh Google city
navigation project and then very
recently reinforcement was used to
control their nuclear fusion plasma okay
so many successful stories
so mathematically reinforced learning is
usually modeled as a market decision
process so in this case in our talk we
are going to focus on infinite Horizon
discounted mdps so we have a finite
State space call it as the finite action
space a and then unknown
action-dependent transient probability
matrices so for each action it's a
transition probability Matrix and it's
unknown
and then we have unknown reward function
which Maps State actions to real values
we assume it's bounded between we assume
it's between zero and one this is
without loss of generality because we
work with finite State action spaces
and finally we have a discount factor
between zero and one okay so in order
for a market decision process to
progress we need to specify how to
choose actions based on the state of the
environment so that strategy or um is
called a policy okay so it can be viewed
as a mapping from State space to action
space or more generally to the
probability sorry to the probability
distribution support data on the action
space
so with a policy at hand so we next
Define how to measure the how good the
policies the performance of the policy
it's captured by the so-called value
function and Q function
so the value function of a policy Pi is
defined in the following so V Pi is a
mapping from State base to real numbers
and its value at State s is defined to
be the total discounted reward here
starting from State s and then follow
the policy Pi thereafter okay so since
we work with Finance State action space
uh the value functions are can be
alternatively built as vectors living in
this s dimensional euclidean space okay
so next let me introduce the two
functions so the similarly Q function is
also a mapping from straight action
space to real numbers and it's defined
to be the total discounted reward
starting from State s but first take in
Action a okay the first action does not
fall down a policy and then follow the
policy thereafter so similarly Q
functions can be viewed as vectors but
living in a larger euclidean space with
Dimension s times a okay
so uh with the value functions and Q
functions defined above so the automate
goal of reinforced learning is to find
an optimal policy Pi star such that the
corresponding value function is
maximized uniformly for or less so it
can be shown that such a policy exists
in this discounted setting
okay so uh this problem is called the
control problem in reinforcement
learning or in general in control theory
so there is a smaller goal in
reinforcement learning which which is
called uh usually called policy
valuation problem so it's to estimate
the value function of a given policy Pi
or uh I mean the value function by value
function I mean either a b function or Q
function of a given policy by so uh this
problem is important for many reasons so
I think most importantly it's a sub
problem in many reinforcement and
algorithms to eventually find an optimal
policy let's say inactive critique or
policy iteration you need to evaluate
the policy before before using this
policy gradient to improve the policy
and this is the prediction problem okay
so this is the startup setup here and
then uh next I will introduce the most
important Concept in reinforcement
learning that will link this talk to CPA
stock
so in C plus talk there's this uh there
there's this operator fixed Point
equation so that operator in this talk
closely related to this so-called
development operator and the fixed Point
equation is the Bellman equation
so let me first introduce the Bellman
equation for uh the policy valuation
okay so here even for policy evaluation
I will think about evaluating uh the Q
function okay to make it consistent with
Q learning like the control problem it
can be used to evaluate V functions too
okay it's like entirely similar
so for Q function uh okay for a given
policy Pi this is the development
equation here so intuitively on the left
hand side is the total discounted reward
starting from State action pair S A on
the right hand side is a combination of
the one stage reward plus discounted
future reward that's why intuitively
they're equal
and this equation can be viewed as a
vector equation since it's for All State
action pairs and to simplify the
notation we introduce the development
operator H pi to capture whatever on the
right hand side so H Pi is the operator
that Maps a q function to another Vector
in the same Dimension space and by by
doing that this is a fixed Point
equation of this element operator here
so it's known that the Spelman operator
is a contractual mapping with respect to
some suitable Norm so this Q Pi is
actually uh the unique solution to this
equation so to this end to solve the
prediction problem which is to estimate
the part estimate the value function of
the policy it's enough to solve this
equation so
okay
and then let me introduce the diamond
equation for the optimal Q function so
this is related to the control problem
so the optimal Q function is defined to
be the Q function associated with the
optimal policy and this is the equation
that satisfies so compared to the
previous equation there is one one
difference so replace so here this AK
plus one is chosen according to the
policy Pi here it is just the one that
maximized Q so this is called
development optimality equation so it
can be shown that this equation uh okay
actually we also introduced the
development optimality operator H to
capture whatever on the right hand side
so this is also a fixed Point equation
and this H is also a contraction mapping
with respect to the L Infinity Norm so
this Q star is actually a unique
solution to this equation here so but
why am I interested in Q star I want to
find the optimal policy so this Spellman
equation actually has a second statement
so this is stated here so if you have
the optimal queue function then by
choosing actions greedily you get back
the optimum policy okay so that's the
motivation of pure learning so
to summarize to find the optimal policy
we only need to find out Mercury
function to do that we only need to
solve this equation because Q star is
the unique solution to this so to this
end both the okay sorry both the policy
valuation problem and the control
problem eventually boils down to solving
fixed Point equations
so uh any questions so far
okay let's first go to the prediction
problem policy valuation
so at a very very high level uh there
are two kinds of algorithms to solve
policy Federation one is Monte Carlo
methods you can view it as a fancy way a
fancy law of large numbers so you want
to estimate the meaning of a random
variable you just collect sequence of
samples and then do the average uh here
we're going to talk about TD learning
which is an iterative way to estimate
the value function of a given policy so
interior learning there there are two
policies that play important role one is
the policy host value function you want
to estimate I mean obviously and the
second one is the policy used to collect
samples which is called the behavior
policy so um when these two are equal
it's called on policy learning when
they're not equal it's called off policy
learning so on policy learning is a
special case of of policy learning but I
want to mention that um
sometimes uh you don't have to choose
the target policy to correct samples and
this is what we're going to focus on
today of policy Theory
so what I'm going to do next is going to
present you a general multi-step of
policy TD learning framework and then
model it as a stochastic approximation
algorithm presented in the previous part
Financial guarantees
okay so before that why of policy
learning uh so there's actually two
reasons from practical point of view and
of the theoretical point of view so
practice your point of view sample
correction can be of high cost and high
risk so to perform on policy learning
whenever you have a policy you need to
use that policy to correct samples but
in certain applications such as robotics
autonomous driving and clinical trials
in healthcare it's not clear how to like
if I want a sample I can have a sample
right it's it's not clear how to do that
so in these cases you you must be able
to like exploit historical data to
perform learning and historical data
sometimes are collected under on their
different policy so inevitably you need
to perform off policy learning okay and
also there's a theoretical reason so uh
we all know that in order to learn you
need to explore but sometimes your
target policy does not have that
exploration component let's say your
target policy is close to deterministic
in this in this case you cannot explore
but choose a nice enough Behavior policy
can ensure exploration okay that's uh
two points of view for the motivation of
policy learning
okay next I'll present the algorithm
framework so uh it's quite complicated
but I will go step by step towards that
so uh let's start with the input so the
input is a sequence of samples uh State
action pairs collected under the
behavior policy pipe so this is a markup
chain okay a marker of chain so when you
fix the behavior policy the mdp becomes
a Markov chain there's no decision to
make and then you just observe how it's
behave and then collect the sequence of
samples
in the next uh TD learning algorithms so
uh probably everyone has seen this
before so I want to uh emphasize two
points for this algorithm first is that
it performs the so-called asynchronous
update so V A qk is your estimate of
your Q Pi which is a vector but every
time you only update one entry of the
vector which corresponds to the entry
that is visited at the case time slot of
your sample directory okay that's the
first thing asynchronous updates the
second thing is that when this entry do
gets updated the amount of updates which
is uh what's up to the step size is just
the difference between the left and the
right of the development equation okay
that's the two points
okay so uh this this algorithm uh is the
standard td0 but uh if you do this
you're going to estimate the value
function of the behavior policy pi b so
this is standard t0 so so in I mean in
order to estimate the value function of
a different policy you need to modify
this algorithm so the way to modify it
is to introduce the so-called important
sampling ratio so of policy TD learning
we add uh like a quantity here and this
quantity is defined to be the the ratio
between the target policy and the
behavior policy okay and this is usually
called the important sampling ratio so
by doing this uh one can show that this
algorithm will converge to the value
function of your target policy okay and
then this ratio is used to like correct
the difference so from this ratio you we
you can see that in order for this ratio
to make sense wherever this uh Pi is
um non-zero pi b must be non-zero okay
for this ratio to be well defined which
means that your behavior policy must
cover at least cover the state action
space that's visited by your target
models so which makes intuitive sense
okay
uh it can't have noise but uh the noise
that it doesn't depend on your policy so
for fixed a state action it can be a
random variable that but the random
randomness is independent of
but here I mean for Simplicity we just
yeah it's a function I mean it's not
known but it's a function of uh State
action
s
yeah
any other questions
okay
so next step so what uh so this is uh
this can be viewed as a policy variant
of on policy td0 or on policy One Step T
but we know that for TD learning there
are many variants like n step tdt number
so why stop at here so we also have a
n-step version of quality TD so to do
end step we just collect the temporal
difference and then sum up sum them up
with this important sampling ratio this
accumulative product of important
sampling ratio okay
so here I have the ratio and here I have
the product of ratios to in order to
correct the difference between the
target policy and the behavior policy so
this is called InStep of velocity
learning which is a counterpart of the
in-step TD in this unpleasant setting
so but it is well known that for
important sampling based uh algorithm
important sampling to introduce this
large variance this is well known even
Beyond reinforcement learning
so in this case we have this uh
trade-off between bias and bearings
because if we use this as the important
sampling ratio then we know that we do
not have bias so our algorithm converge
to the true Target value function of the
target policy but the problem is that
the product of important ratios has
large parents and it's actually
multiplied by another random variable
which make it even worse so uh what
people do is that to overcome such high
variance people replace the important
sampling ratio by the so-called
generalized important sampling ratio so
it's here so instead of using the ratio
between the two policies you just
replaced it by some function depending
on the state action pairs if this
function is just the ratio then you get
back the previous algorithm but uh it's
more flexible because you can choose
other functions in order to buy balance
the bias variance trade-off in this type
of policy Peter learning algorithms
uh we didn't uh this is a general
framework but many existing algorithms
fit into this framework so uh for
example
in this uh uh redmi mono's paper in 2016
called Uh there's our algorithm TD
learning called retrace number so in
this algorithm the row is chosen to be
the important sampling ratio but the C
is chosen okay okay by the way so for
generalized important sampling this uh C
and row doesn't have to be the same
function okay previously they're the
same the ratio and here they they can
that doesn't have to be the same okay so
this row is just the ratio but the C is
number times the mean between 1 and the
ratio so intuitively this actually helps
overcoming the high variance because
let's say if this ratio is large you
just truncated and one and then
artificially like preventing it from
being too large okay so but uh by doing
this uh you may think that since I
changed the ratio it may not converge to
the optimal I don't know it may not
converge to the True Value function B Pi
so that's the trade-off here okay so
there are many algorithms uh that can
fit into this framework so I listed a
few here I think this algorithm is
called Q Pi number this is three backup
denominator and this one is uh okay this
one is called B trace and this one is
actually the one used in this Google
city navigation project okay
so any questions so far so this is the
algorithm
okay so next I'm going to do is I'm
going to I mean we're going to establish
Finance sample guarantees of this
algorithm so I'm going to reformulate
this algorithm as a stochastic
approximation algorithm presented in the
previous part and then establish Finance
sample pumps So currently this looks
nothing like that right there's I mean
it's much more complicated than that
okay so let's do the reformulation so um
I want to go go over this slowly because
eventually this idea can be used to like
reformulate most of the value-based
reinforcement learning algorithms in
that framework
okay so this is the algorithm I
presented in the previous slide so let's
first focus on this blue term this thing
after the step size this is a random
variable no doubt like a very
complicated one but it's a deterministic
function of this set of random variables
okay so once qk is fixed and SK up to SK
plus one A K plus n are fixed this thing
is a deterministic number okay so I'll
just introduce a function f to capture
this write it as a function of these
random variables okay this is just for
Simplicity of a notation okay
next uh I have this asynchronous update
okay so which is very painful so it's
just I mean we just introduced an
indicator function to capture that and
then we can write this like it looks
like a synchronous update it's like for
All State action pairs although like uh
in nature it's still asynchronous update
okay
so now we're close but still we don't
have this FX minus X structure so in
order to have that we need this whole
thing to be something like fqky k s a
minus qk sa right so this is simple we
just uh we want this to be that we move
this to this side we just Define f to be
listing plus q k okay if we Define it
that way then the algorithm can be
written in this form okay so uh this is
a synchronous update so no no
asynchronism here and then we have this
fq minus Cube structure like like a
fixed Point equation
okay so uh let let's map this to the
algorithms we've presented earlier so
recall that um
so this is the algorithm in the previous
part
and this is used to solve some F Bar of
x equal to X
where F Bar is the expectation of this
taking expectation with respect to the
random variable y k i mean I mean the
stationary distribution of the random
variable y k okay so our qk here is x k
here and y k is this sequence of random
variables so uh we know that when the
policy is fixed uh skk forms a Markov
chain but actually this long sequence is
also a Markov chain if you think about
it because if this is given then the
next state action is also I mean the
distribution is determined by the
transient probabilities and then it's
still a marketing okay although I mean
uh it's longer I mean the mixing time
may be different okay
and then also uh this double click here
in this case is identically equal to
zero so we have this reformulation ready
so any questions about the reformulation
I think the key here is to
um
is to formulate this uh indicator
function into the operator so previously
for asynchronous reinforcement and
algorithms it's like analyzed separately
the noise here and the noise here but
here because of our formulation it's
like uh one shot estimate a One-Shot
analysis of Mars carbon stochastic
approximation
okay so next uh we have the formulation
ready we're going to uh verify the
assumptions so uh Siva has three
assumptions I think he didn't represent
all of them but actually uh we have so
we need Lipschitz continuity of the
noise the operator with respect to q and
we need it to be uniform for all y okay
and we need geometric geometric mixing
of the marketing YK and the contraction
property of the expected operator F Bar
so the first two is actually uh
relatively simple so think about the
second one if uh if your behavior policy
is fixed then uh suppose it induced
exotic marketing on the states and then
it took that you took that Tuple it's
also going to be geometric mixing okay
so uh the probably seemingly most
obvious but actually non-obvious part is
the third one okay the contraction
property of the operator F Bar so this
is related to development operator but
not exactly the same
let me explain okay so in the very
simple case let's say one step on policy
PD so this can be viewed as a special
case of the algorithm framework I
presented earlier just taking the target
policy equal to the behavior policy and
then choose the important sampling ratio
to be one okay
so in this case f bar is has this
formula so H here is the one step
development operator we presented
earlier which is a contraction mapping D
here is a matrix diagonal matrix with
the stationary distribution of State
action pairs on the diagonal okay
now uh to make sense of it let's look at
entry-wise okay for for a corresponding
State action pair we have this formula
here so uh f-bar operator if you view it
this way it can be viewed as the
expectation of a random variable which
takes Q with probability 1 minus mu S A
and takes H Pi Q with probability new
essay so this uh this if you think about
this captures the asynchronous update in
the algorithm because it kind of says
that if that entry is visited I'm going
to go towards this direction if that
entry is not visited which is with this
probability at least asymptotically I'm
going to stay where I am okay
in our paper we call it uh the
asynchronous Spellman operator okay
okay so uh now the next question is uh
we we know that the synchronous
government operator H5 is a contract
mapping is the asynchronous element
operator also contract mapping okay so
if this mu uh are not essay dependent
let's say mu is a constant four essay
then this is like obvious it's just
triangle inequality that's it
but when this mu are different it's like
doing a convex combination for
entry-wise convex combination but across
entries they're different then this is
not entirely clear
so in fact if you have
a general operator which is contraction
mapping then doing this may not result
in a contraction mapping with respect to
the same Norm okay so uh here uh
actually this captures all the
algorithms uh I presented earlier let's
say uh for off policy PD and step TD uh
one part uh one step TD this F operator
is of this form and this T operator here
is the corresponding synchronous element
operator okay
what we can show is the following let's
say suppose T is the contraction mapping
with respect to some Norm then I mean in
general it may not be a contraction
mapping with respect to the same Norm
this F Bar but in some special cases
which is true so uh in those actually
those cases are enough for for us to
study reinforcement learning
so first if the norm is the L Infinity
Norm okay then it doesn't matter uh the
special what kind of special structure
you have for this operator if the norm
of contraction is the super Norm then F
Bar is also a contractor mapping with
this as the contraction parameter here
so so first why super Norm is is special
here because if you think about soup
Norm it's like taking the largest entry
so you're you're doing entry-wise convex
combination and then you take the
largest entries it's going to be a
contraction as well okay that's the
special property of supron that enables
us to show this and also if you look at
the contraction Factor here so um it's
actually larger because of doing
asynchronous updates I mean if you do
synchronous update then you can think of
it as a special case of this where D is
the identity Matrix okay if this is
identity then the minimum entry of the
diagonal entry is also one and then one
minus this one will cancel you get back
the contraction factor and then because
of doing asynchronous update the
contraction factor is larger it's like a
convex combination between one and the
the I mean the original Contracting
Factor okay so this is enough for us to
analyze all reinforcement learning
algorithms because they are all
supernormal contractions but we have a
stronger result because we know in TD
learning you it's not it's not only a
contraction mapping with respect to
supernormally it's a contractual mapping
with respect to many many other drones
so we can exploit that
in fact interior learning we show that
for on policy TD and stability
denominator and the off policy TD I
presented earlier the F Bar operator is
a contraction mapping with uh with the
same contraction Factor but with respect
to weighted Pinon for all people and one
to Infinity okay
so this is uh the contraction property
so uh until now we verified all the
assumptions uh next um I'll present the
result so uh before that any questions
about the contraction here
okay
oh yeah uh okay the weight is um okay
it's not the stationary distribution uh
it's it's related but it's not the
stationary distribution but we can show
that it's strictly positive and um
yeah but eventually uh when we present
the bond we present the bound with uh
unweighted norms
it's related but it's not exactly the
same so because if it's one step TD one
policy then then it is new but if it's
in step 3D and you also have this
generalized important sampling ratios
then it will deviate from you
we know that in a way
these contraction factors are tied
yeah so because uh let's say if B is
identity no not anything like part of
the current
then it's just final inequality I mean
you can construct an example yeah but
what I mean is that this dependence and
teaming has to be there and stuff like
that
that's a good question so
from operating point of view it will
probably have like other structures say
reinforcement I believe this is time
okay yeah but uh if you use other I mean
okay in reinforce learning it's like uh
there are many ways of analyzing here we
take this approach so that this new mean
appears let's say once Deputy on policy
then we have the minimum presentation of
the station distribution that will
appear I mean there are many other
analysis like different parameters like
equivalents will appear some some people
use this covering time which is spending
the time to visit all specific action
thereof and then there are many many
other similar Concepts but in advocates
what I mean is that for example if you
just take the uh
the the standard I don't know very
tradition or whatnot you know that the
speed that needs to get convergence in a
worst case sense exactly related to the
discount Factor right uh so in terms of
the contraction properties of the
operator that's like tight and then it
is and and now you might wonder about
okay you have this modified operators
what's the Titan analysis for these uh
do we have the same
okay I don't know the answer to that
okay
um
I thought fitting is true but uh okay to
say that we could see a minute
but I think I think intuitively I mean
so um so the bank should depend on the
minimum visitation of State action sets
right because you're doing eight
different subject but you know not
visiting it then it's not getting
updated
foreign
move forward
okay okay I should speed up okay uh okay
this is a weaver about all the
assumptions now let's State the results
uh I will not State the finance sample
Bound in save us like in C bus for labor
I mean it's too complicated I'm going to
State just the sample complexity
so in order to achieve uh the area Okay
I want to point out this qk is our
iterate Q Pi row is the limit point
which may not be equal to 2 pi because
we're not we're not using the exact
important sampling ratio there may be
some bias but I will provide a bound on
such bias okay so in order to achieve
this error the sample complexity is I
mean the amount of samples is of this
order here
so in terms of one original Square this
is optimal I mean think of a lot of
large numbers and then uh the second one
is uh the dependence on the size of the
state action space and also the
effective Horizon and the third one is
the dependence on the important sampling
ratios so uh in order to Define this
rigorously I need two pages of notation
so I choose not to do that but I'll tell
you that it's an increasing function of
the maximum value of C function and low
function okay so that's why that if you
truncate the important sampling ratio
then somehow this max value becomes
smaller and then you have a smaller
value here which means that your
variance is
smaller okay so that's um the trade-off
uh the I mean the I mean impact of
choosing important sampling visuals
any questions about this result
okay so next I'll present uh the band I
promise so uh so the difference between
the True Value function and the limit
point Q payroll can be bounded in the
following manner here so on the left
hand side we see so this Cube Arrow
depends only on the choice of road so
recall that we have two important
sampling ratios one is inside the
temporal difference one is outside the
temporal difference which you are doing
this product the outside one this C1
where you're doing product it doesn't
matter so it doesn't have any impact on
the limit point only the one that's
inside the temporal difference will
change your limit point
and the way it changes it's uh according
to this inequality zero is a constant on
the right hand side if you stare at this
expression you'll see that this will be
zero because the right hand side will be
zero if your row is exactly the
important sampling ratio okay if you
choose something something different
than that then you may get a bias so
from this result then you can see that
for this uh off policy TD learning in
order to buy a balance the bias variance
trade-off you should somehow choose the
Rogue oh sorry choose row close to this
uh important sampling here so that you
do not have many like high high bias and
then you choose small C so that you have
uh like low variance so that's the
takeaway takeaway message from this
theorem
so any questions because uh next I will
switch switch gear to the control
problem
so last last sentence so uh actually uh
so this is for off policy on step TD so
we have uh like I show you how to uh
like reformulate as speculation
approximation and apply save as result
we can do this for onstep and step TD on
policy and skeptidity on policy TD
number and we get the like the finance
sample bound too okay
so next uh the control problem
so uh first do a high level overview so
the control problem also at the high
level there are two kinds of algorithms
one is actor critique uh like also
policy space methods including like
actual critique natural actor critique
policy iteration I mean approximate
policy iteration so Siva talked about it
in this joint ifml data-driven decision
process workshop on Friday you can look
at the video there here I'm going to
focus on Q learning which is this value
values-based methods and specifically
I'm going to talk about both tabular
learning and also cure learning with
linear function approximation okay LFA
stands for linear function approximation
okay so let's first do a recall so uh
why why curing okay it's because of the
development equation so Q star uniquely
solves this and then we introduce
development operator to capture the
right hand side so this is a fixed Point
equation with a contractive operator so
unique solution and then why doing this
because pyth salary Stark makes up this
that's why we want to learn Q
no cure learning so um
okay so similarly we have a sequence of
State actions pairs uh that's generated
by some Behavior policy so here I'm
assuming this policy is fixed and uh
sufficiently exploitative but in
practice people use different kind of
even time varying Behavior policies such
as like soft Max or Epsilon greedy okay
here I'm going to fix uh like uh
I'm going to make the policy fixed
so next I'll present the Quran algorithm
here so uh this is entirely similar to
the one-step TD learning the only
difference I mean we have uh
asynchronous update that's the first
point and then uh the update the amount
of updates is the difference between the
left and the right of the Belmont
equation and the only difference between
this and the one step TD is that I have
this Max operator here so uh this Max
changes everything because uh previously
it's a linear stack approximation now
because of this Max it becomes
non-linear and then all the difficulties
such as supernum contraction the
convergence of under function
approximation are all because of this
okay
so this is the algorithm so next uh I'll
present the final sample analysis but
before that the reformulation but I
think this part is entirely similar we
Define the F function which is a
function of four uh arguments because
under this I mean if these four
arguments are given the amount of update
is deterministic and then we Define this
similar in this off policy TD and then
we can reformulate uh Q learning as a
like a markovianistic acid approximation
in queue learning case this F Bar
operator is defined similarly to be
component wise convex combination
between the Bellman operator and
identity operator with the convex
combination parameter being the station
distributions okay so since Q learning
it's known that uh the Belmont operator
here is a contraction mapping with
respect to soup Norm so I want to point
out that unlike TD learning so in TD
learning the development operator is
known to be a contraction mapping with
respect to many many Norms but in Q
learning at least to my knowledge it's
only a contraction mapping with respect
to Superman okay but super Norm is good
enough we know that when it's super Norm
then this FR operator is known to be a
contractor mapping with respect to the
same norm and then with this larger
contraction Factor okay
okay so uh next uh with this where we
can apply the result in uh previous part
so in order to achieve this error the
number of samples is of this order here
so in terms of Epsilon Square in terms
of the accuracy Epsilon it's optimal
because I mean flow of large numbers as
a special case and then in terms of the
effect of horizon it's uh one over uh
one minus gamma to the power five so
this doesn't match the lower bound uh
it's because the lower bound is like um
the lower Bound in lower bound is one
over one is gamma to the power three
this does match that because uh Q I mean
the lower bound is uh information
theoretic lower bounds so it doesn't
depend on the algorithm but Q learning
the vanilla coordinary algorithm does
not achieve that but there are existing
literature showing that if you add
various reduction then uh that Q
learning algorithm will achieve the
lower bound yeah please
you learning no important sampling no
yeah
oh yeah so similarly I mean that you
first Define a small F to capture all
the and then use the indicator and then
scheduling is is of policy but you don't
use importance that's the interesting
part you use the max yeah
okay any questions
so where did you use like 5B you don't
despair
can actually yeah this streaming will
show up uh eventually in the bounce I I
didn't present it I think it's to the
power
but you don't need like
I mean you need to correct samples right
so you need a policy to collect sample
yeah let's say you have the sound
effects
so if you have examples you don't need
to know piping but the minimum frequency
of visiting State action pairs of your
samples that should also appear That's
the equivalence of the rudimentary
station distribution if you use the
policy to practice
but but as I said earlier uh in practice
I don't think people use a fixed
Behavior policy I think that's an
artifact of the proof practice people
use Epson radio or this soft Max in that
case this policy player will yeah but in
terms of analysis that's much harder
because the corresponding Markov chain
is not time homogeneous and we don't I
mean under that it's hard to talk about
like a station distribution sort of
class
any other questions
okay so uh final part so um
so this is we have uh we have presented
of policy TV and Q running both in the
tabular setting but we know that
reinforcement learning does not work
well with tabular because of the cursive
dimensionality so let's say in Q
learning every time you're only update
to one entry of the Q Vector which is of
the size s times a and let's say in a
game of Go s is like offsides 10 to the
power 120 so it's not going to work so
we need to use function approximation
okay so uh next let's dive into function
approximation Q learning with function
approximation specifically okay so um
let's first present the uh approximation
architecture here so we use linear
function approximation which means that
we choose uh feature basis or a set of
future vectors file 1 to 5D okay we're
going to approximate optimal queue
function using linear combinations of
these basis vectors so this is just
notation here I call each column Phi Phi
I and then Phi I is the sa dimensional
object now each row I call it Phi of s a
and it's a d dimensional object okay
so by doing this uh the good thing is
that instead of having s a number of
free parameters I only have D number of
parameters so by doing this I like
artificially reduce the complexity of
the problem okay but uh the bad part of
this is that uh
it's not clear if your Optima queue
function can be represented this way
okay so it might be possible that the
optimal Q function does not belong to
the linear Subspace and then in this
case it's not clear how to construct a
stable algorithm that converts to
something close to the optimal Q
function okay so next I'll first present
the Manila Quran algorithm and then I'll
present a modified version of that which
is I think used I think it's it's extent
I mean it's a neural network parent was
used in this particular and it has
connection with fitted queue iteration
I'm going to present later
so okay so this is Basis Vector so this
is the vanilla children algorithm okay
so we also have a uh like first I mean
we collect samples According to some
Behavior policy so we can either do it
in the online manner offline manner it
doesn't matter and then uh we update the
corresponding weight Vector so note that
here we only need to calculate the
correct weight Vector which is a d
Dimension object so according to this
formula here so compared to vanilla Q
running uh in the tabular setting there
is only actually one difference so this
is the temporary difference is exactly
the same note that this Pi transpose
Theta is actually our so it's their the
Q function of sa I mean the sa entry of
the Q function
okay and then the only difference is
that you multiply the temporal
Difference by the feature vector and
then update it to the weight Vector here
okay so uh to make sense of this update
let's say in the tablet setting in this
case my feature Matrix is an identity
Matrix okay so in this case the
algorithm this algorithm get you back to
the tabular Q learning in that tablet
setting so this file will be just a
vector with one entry being one and
other entries being zero okay
so um so this algorithm was proposed I
think 30 years ago okay and then
probably 20 years ago there is a counter
example
so the counter example is in
okay nearly 20 uh yeah near more than 20
years ago okay so the counter example is
the following so uh so the exact example
I'm going to not going to present
there's an mdp example so you can look
at paper for more details I'm going to
present two things first is uh the graph
so we see that classical q-learning with
the linear function approximation
diverges exponentially fast okay so this
is the log time scale exponentially
Divergence and another thing I want to
point out for this country example is
the following so in this example
the number of Weights is equal to the
number of straight action pairs so which
means that you are not doing linear
function proximation you're doing a
change of basis so if you go back to the
previous uh here so this Matrix was
supposed to be a like thin Matrix but if
D is equal to sa is like a square Matrix
okay
and then so you're essentially doing a
change of basis but surprisingly even in
this setting the algorithm diverges so
that suggests that the algorithm should
I mean should be flawed right I mean if
it's just change of basis I mean nothing
changes I mean in nature nothing changes
but the algorithm diverges okay so uh in
one of my previous papers we have
another example showing that the
Divergence can happen with a strict
inequality okay so this suggests that uh
the algorithm you should modify the
algorithm so next I will introduce uh
how to modify it so the eventually the
algorithm is called cool learning with
Target Network and truncation and then
I'll show you how to get there step by
step from the vanilla children algorithm
so this is a millennial pure learning so
let's first introduce the target Network
so here this data K here I will replace
it by something Theta hat okay so and
then with index T so which means that
when you update it for Theta K this is
not changing okay so this is called the
target Network parameter and then you
need to update the target Network and
then you do it in the auto Loop and then
you just synchronize it to the last
iterate of the inner loop okay this is
called Target Network so intuitively why
Target Network helps I mean eventually I
mean mathematically will help but
intuitively why it helps it's because I
mentioned earlier everything that that
makes Q learning more challenging is
because of the max operator okay let's
say you fix this data hat in this Max
then this update in terms of theta K is
a linear spec as approximation nothing
non-linear here this is fixed this is
not updated so that's why intuitively
it's like more stable okay this is the
first thing and the second truncation
okay so truncation is here so let's
first Define the truncation operator the
translation operator is defined for
let's say uh for scaling and then if
it's a vector then it's like an entryway
operator so it's uh defined in the
following way so we have a truncation
radius R and then we'll choose R to be
one over minus gamma which is uh the
uniform upper bound of all Q functions
because our reward is between 0 and 1.
and then if this value is above or we
choose R if it's between then a B2 minus
i and r we don't change it and then if
it's less than minus r which is minus r
okay so uh this is the function operator
and then the way it works is that we
impose it here and then this whole thing
uh we truncated before taking the max so
intuitively this this is also like
dealing with massaging this next
operator so essentially the target
Network and truncation I mean all both
of them are trying to massage this Max
operator so that it's like more stable
okay
okay
so uh next I want to point out something
so there is an interesting connection
between uh children with Target Network
and truncation and this fitted curation
so this is uh so this target Network
this this is called in this deep Q
network uh paper in 2015 where they they
call it Target network but uh the
connection between Target Network and
Affiliated Q iteration is the following
so if you recall fit EQ iteration uh
it's like giving a fixed set of samples
every time I solve uh the minimize
development error and then iterate it so
if you use stochastic gradient descent
to minimize okay so first if you in the
linear function approximation setting
and then if you use stochastic gradient
descent to minimize the Bellman error
and also if you don't use a fixed set of
samples use a single category of samples
meaning that every time uh suppose I use
the first 10 samples for the first
iteration and then 11 to 20 if you do
that with these then uh Q learning with
Target Network can be viewed as an
online updated graduation okay
so uh any questions so far
so next I'll present the results
so unlike vanilla killer is going to
diverge and so this algorithm is going
to stay stable so the Assumption here is
that the behavior policy is positive for
all actions and induces a uniformly
economic marketing okay
and uh this is the result here
so under this assumption for uh the
inner loop iteration number should be
chosen hard enough and then we have the
following result for all key greater
requirement and zero where T is this uh
Auto Loop iteration number so the left
hand side here is the difference between
the optimal Q function and the Q
function associated with Target Network
okay and the right hand side consists of
four terms so the first term I call it
error due to fixed Point iteration uh
why that's because um let's say if
you're not using function approximation
meaning that you are using Identity or
feature mix Matrix and also suppose you
don't have any own noise which means you
can do fixed Point iteration then you
will have geometric convergence which is
captured by the first term so in that
case this is the only area term you're
going to have so that's uh the area due
to fix Point iteration and the second
and third term it looks like the terms
in siva's talk right this um
uh finite sample bound the first
geometric the second constant so we're
using constant step size here so this is
the stochastic error in the Inner Loop
okay
and the last thing I call it function
approximation error so because uh the
optimal Q function may not belong to
your function class so in this case uh
you do not expect to this to converge to
zero in general and then the error is
captured by this and explicitly this is
defined in the following way it's soup
over all Q functions in your approximity
function class which is your linear
Subspace and also the Q function should
be bounded in supron by one over one
gamma and then this value here so this
captures uh the approximation power of
your function plus so let's consider
several special cases so first if your
uh if you're in the calculator setting
which means that um your feature Matrix
is identity okay okay so so first before
that I need to mention this so Pi here
is a projection onto your linear
Subspace with respect to some weighted
tune on okay
so if you are uh in this a tabular
setting then your linear Subspace is
actually your whole Space which means
that that uh the the uh this uh
projection operator is identity and then
in this case if this is exactly equal to
zero so we don't have function
approximation error this is X expected
and the second special case if your uh
feature Matrix is not identity but let's
say Square invertible which is the case
of uh bias counter example if you recall
in this case this is also identity
because it's a change of basis your
linear Subspace is still your whole
space and then this is still a zero so
which means that this algorithm will
achieve convergence to zero for bias
counter example okay
so in the Third special case is uh in
existing literature there's this
so-called completeness assumption so it
says that under completeness assumption
for every queue in your Subspace HQ is
also in your Subspace this is the
statement of completeness assumption
under that assumption this is also zero
okay and then if that is not satisfied
then this captures the approximation
power of your function class because uh
if your function is Rich then you would
expect this to be small
okay
uh and then this is a picture
characterizing this so this is Q This is
H of Q you project it back and then this
is the difference
any questions about the statement of the
results
okay so uh now I've shown that uh with a
modified algorithm adding truncation and
uh Target network uh the previous
Divergent algorithm is provably stable
so but why is that um
the next slide can be viewed as a proof
okay sorry uh okay yeah sorry
so
[Music]
but
what if you just did that also as much
is that the same
that's pretty too delicious so does it
make a difference in some sense
thank you
so I think it's qualification could lose
a little bit but if you do it well
it's kind of hard to do it well
it's just like yeah yeah
I think there's another probably another
difference if you use a batch setting uh
let's say you have a generated model
then you can probably choose where to
sample the state action page and then to
make this so here uh I'm hiding a lot of
constant here that's what say for
example there's a minimum eigenvalue of
the matrix by transport speed but that
will appear in advance if you use a
batch of samples and then you do let me
carefully sample where to transit to the
state action test probably you can
overcome that limitation
yeah I'm not changing the way
I forgot this when I presented earlier
so this is the sample complexity
guarantee so in order to achieve this
error let's say it's not plus the
function approximation error which is
what you cannot overcome doesn't matter
how many iterations you run and then the
number of the sample complexities of
this order so one of which one square
times one over one was gamma to the
power four so this is the sample complex
three of Q learning with the linear
function approximation
uh okay so next I'll present uh a proof
sketch of this uh which is no I mean no
math Okay so
okay actually sorry before that let's
present some numerical simulations so I
said earlier that uh pure learning uh
with linear function approximation it
diverges for byte counter example so
here for the new algorithm it converges
here as we see it goes to zero and also
for my counter example in my previous
work it also achieves convergence okay
so um yeah so that's uh
I mean empirically it works so yeah
okay so the algorithm is stable but why
so this is the proof sketch here so uh
let's take a step back so oh sorry let's
just take a step back so tabular queue
learning so why is it stable it's
because it's a deterministic version of
Q uh value iteration and Q value
iteration is stable because it's a fixed
Point iteration of contraction operators
and then Q learning with uh tablet
setting as a stochastic variant of that
is also stable so that's why it
communities and then for uh vanilla pure
learning with the linear function
approximation the deterministic variant
is something like this so um it's like
fixed Point iteration but you have this
feature Matrix and then by looking at
this it's it's I mean it's no longer a
fixed Point iteration of this H because
of function approximation okay and then
there's no contraction operator here so
this algorithm is actually unstable
actually we can simulate the
deterministic version of this in those
counter examples and you can also
observe damages that's why we need a q
learning as a stochastic variant of
something which is already unstable it
doesn't coverage okay
and then finally Quran with Target
Network and communication the
deterministic version of this is called
truncated projected Bowman iteration
okay so it's uh so first uh
we have this by Theta K here we first
truncate it with a truncation radius and
then use the Belmont operator and then
project it back back to the linear
Subspace and then call it Phi Theta K
plus 1 okay
you can show that this is stable
truncated development projectable
iteration
and then currently with Target Network
as a stochastic variant of this is also
stable so that's essentially the proof
sketch
so when you prove it uh just first show
this is stable and then bound there
right between this and this
okay so uh this is uh now let's do a
quick summary so in this talk we
presented uh the convergence analysis of
many reinforcement and algorithms
especially uh we present we first
present InStep TD learning with off
policy sampling and generalized
important sampling ratios and then uh we
actually it can be applied to on policy
and skeptidity number two so due to time
limited I did I didn't present it here
so uh and then we also presented Q
learning using this uh supernum
contraction and then finally we
presented two learning with linear
function approximation so
uh the recipe to apply the stochastic
Proclamation results to the all these
algorithms is the following so we first
reformulate uh the algorithm into the
Markov against approximation to do that
we need to introduce the the key part
there is to introduce the indicator
function and then calculate this
asynchronous Bellman operator and then
show the contraction property
okay and then we just apply this to cast
approximation result in part one so
that's the recipe here so uh this is the
end of the talk uh thank you all for
listening and uh please let me know if
you have any questions
[Applause]
yeah so maybe you can add a little more
explanation for the previous slide of
why
the very last one is stable
what what is being used there that makes
that stable how do you argue Okay so
but yeah but uh okay think about this
one so so first let's say consider
change of Basics by the current sample
okay in this case the projection
operator is identity and then even
without truncation it slowly covered
because
okay now let's uh if uh it's not change
of basis then the fundamental problem of
theories so the fundamental problem like
you're learning the function
transformation can diverge is the order
so the H operator is a contraction
method with respect to suit norms and
the only
and the projection operator is the
company's Dynamic scientific method with
respect to the projection in this case
I'm working tomorrow so the fundamental
reason for the Divergence is that the
combination I mean the computation
between these small projects
okay now let's take a different
Viewpoint so let's view this as an
approximate way of doing this
development operator without projection
and then let's view the error as uh
there between H and uh the projection so
H minus projection of H let's view this
as an error okay so in this Viewpoint uh
purely beverages because the error may
be unbounded
okay and then this translation issues
that they already started so because of
translation the area is between
something bounded and the projection of
something passes and then the difference
is also founded the translation plays a
keyboard
I think stable in the sense that
like what the open of course stable
which is like doesn't explode
fine I can have a lot of algorithms that
do not explode this doesn't make it a
good algorithm
so I used to work very carefully there I
didn't say asymptotic conversions it's
not allergies everything was correct
scientifically correct so uh okay it's
not like uh if you do projections then
everything is well inside the projection
set it's not and this is not like that
so uh it's like so if you do this then
in the special cases of either capital
or gender phases or completeness you
will have an almost recover this because
functional transformation error will be
zero and then if you are in the function
approximation setting it's not like a
something uh like anything random in
your projection set it's like oh yeah
this function approximation error that
captures how much you're always going to
do but I agree with you that um I think
so you had the approximation error there
so right like in the Farms yeah
which was the spam on
right like that blah blah blah
and uh
right so you expect
a fixed point of a
big because of this right like and
eventually this is
what is saving things without transition
okay without truncation the only
difference is that you do not have this
right then it's going to be Infinity
yeah
okay I really think that um I think this
problem is far from solved uh so the
lack of passion convergence I think is a
major issue including with contract
oxidation
so I think it's it's some probably it's
the same condition that could complete
as well most of the papers if you see
it's like the bound is something
converged to zero plus function
approximation error that does not
Implement your companies
stop
over there I'm happy with the lack of
asymptotic convergence if you are in a
small boat maybe you can be unhappy
about this uh definition of the
approximation error which requires that
for a lot of functions things like
functional space is capturing what
happens if you apply the operator to the
function
so actually these two questions are
related so suppose you have asymptotic
conversions then you don't need the soup
here you will you will get rid of the
soup and then we place cubes by the
Milling point just like uh the opinion
learning with the linear function
approximation specifically
so it's because of less lack of
asymptotic convergence we have this too
yes
you need to approximate that point right
I'm thinking about the negative results
or calculating
sample efficiently Q star under linear
realizability
so we have information Theory lower
balance yeah to tell us that that's not
possible what are the term you're using
and no connecting that to what you do
yeah I mean it's not complete okay so
because
maybe it's suggesting that
not to say anything positive like in the
way you want it to right like if you
would make the area term
okay imagine that you designed a
conversion director of any food Hall
that it converges to this point and the
approximation there could be modified
like that and that would suddenly
contradict unless the sample size is
somehow exponential action that are on
qualities
so the lower bound is an algorithm
independent lower bond that says that
from the Q sterilized solidity if you
have large enough imperfections
[Music]
but there is an event right now that's
starting at 4 30 so yeah so it's an
event to honor Peter Bartlett's
contribution to Science Institute who
was the associate director of the last
five years
joint reception for all the programs so
I think if you need to take videos
thank you